[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci
bonsoir tout le monde ça va
vous savez quand j'étais enfant
j'aimais pas trop la salle de classe
parce que j'avais du mal à me concentrer
alors je regardais souvent par la
fenêtre pressé d'aller retrouver les
copains jouer mes vins des et un jour je
me suis retrouvé chez mon voisin qui m'a
ouvert la porte de tous les possibles
et cet effet son propre vidéo club 500
cas cette vidéo 500 films
c'est comme s'il avait trouvé un remède
contre l'ennui et moi ça m'a amené
directement dans une autre classe la
salle de cinéma
alors je sais pas si le cinéma c'est
l'école de la vie mais en tout cas ça a
été la mienne
et c'est la raison pour laquelle ce soir
je veux le remercier
parce qu'il est mon meilleur mentor
le cinéma m'a aussi appris et continue
d'ailleurs avoir d'autres horizons avoir
notre passé parfois percevoir le futur
aussi
mais surtout avoir les différences il
m'a rappelé à regarder l'autre celle
c'est lui qui nous ressemble pas qui
parle une autre langue qui mange dans un
autre plat qui écoute une autre musique
qui vit différemment quoi
et puis le cinéma c'est très cool aussi
parce que c'est juste le meilleur pote
que tu viens d'avoir il t'apprend à
draguer à t'habiller un résilient à te
comporter être courageux entre bel et à
pardonner et à aimer
c'est aussi le meilleur conseiller
d'orientation parce qu'il a le pouvoir
de créer des vocations il donne envie
d'être docteur agriculteurs sportif
policier reporter enfin tout ce qu'on
rêve d'être
l'art du rêve que cette école parle à
tout le monde même à celui qui ne sait
pas lire écrit au comté tout le monde y
trouve sa place les intellos les cancres
les dociles les Grandes Gueules les
curieux
d'ailleurs cette cérémonie c'est un peu
c'est un peu la fête de fin d'année aux
personnes Nord double et où on va
raconter toutes les émotions qu'on a eu
la chance de partager cette année
en fait moi je vois du cinéma partout je
vois tout par ce prisme pour moi
quelqu'un dans la rue c'est un scénario
qui marche quand je bois un beau paysage
c'est un chef d'écho qui a bien bossé et
puis quand j'admire à lever de soleil je
me dis je me dis que le chef est très
fort
alors nous qui faisons du cinéma on est
comme ça on se nourrit du public on lui
emprunte une scène de sa vie et on lui
rend en image sur grand écran alors
c'est simple sans le public il y a pas
de nous parce que sans lui il y a pas de
cinéma pas seulement parce qu'il y a
personne pour regarder les films mais
surtout il n'y a pas de matière pas de
magie
c'est pour ça qu'il y a pas de frontière
entre ceux qui font le cinéma ceux qui
vont en voir ils sont tous spectateurs
et acteurs ils sont tous dans la même
équipe on est tous dans la même école
c'est donc pour toutes ces raisons que
nous gens qui faisons du cinéma
ouverte
[Applaudissements]